[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من لندن تزامنا مع
تقرير عن ان بريطانيا تدرس تزويد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات لاول مره لمساعدتها على تصدي
للقوات الروسيه
الى العاصمه البرازيليه والمشهد على الارض
غدا تم وصف باسمه هجوم على مؤسسات الدوله
منذ عوده البرازيل للحكم الديمقراطي في
ثمانينيات القرن الماضي
والى هذا المخيم للنازحين السوريين بريف
ادلب على الحدود السوريه التركيه تزامنا
مع موافقه مجلس الامن الدولي بالاجماع على
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه لنحو اربعه
ملايين سوري
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
تصاعد المعارك على جبهات الشرق في
اوكرانيا جبهه بخموت الاكثر اشتعالا وصدى
قتال عنيف
وبعد تعويضات باسلحه من الولايات المتحده
وفرنسا والمانيا بريطانيا تدرس تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات قتاليه لاول مره الكريم
لم يقول ان تسليمه اوكرانيا مدرعات غربيه
واسلحه اخرى لن يغير موازين القوى
وسط تصاعدي معاناه اكثر من اربعه ملايين
نازح سوري مجلس الامن يقرر بالاجماع تمديد
اليه نقل المساعدات الانسانيه الى سوريا
عبر الحدود لسته اشهر واشنطن ترحب وتقول
ان التبديد كان ينبغي ان يكون لمده عام
وموسكو تصف اقرار التمديد بالقرار الصعب
وتقول انه لا يغير موقفها المبدا من اليه
المساعدات
بهدف في تشكيل حكومه مدنيه وحل قضايا
عالقه الاطراف السودانيه تبدا محادثات
للتوصل الى اتفاق نهائيا بشان المرحله
الانتقاليه مسؤول سوداني يقول ان النقاشات
متواصله مع المعارضين للاتفاق الايطالي
وممثل الوساطه الدوليه السفير النرويجي في
السودان يؤكد للجزيره ان الجيش سينفذ وعده
بالعوده الى سكناته
غداه اسوا هجوم على مؤسسات الدوله منذ
عوده البرازيل للحكم الديمقراطي تشديد
الاجراءات الامنيه في العاصمه رؤساء
السلطات التنفيذيه والتشريعيه والقضائيه
يعتبرون اقتحام المؤسسات عمليه انقلابيه
لولاد سيلفا يستانف العمل في القصر
الرئاسي وانقل الى مستشفى في فلوريدا
مستشاره الامن القومي الامريكي يقول ان
واشنطن لم تتلقى اي طلب رسميا من برازيليا
بشان الرئيس السابق
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا المشهد في البرازيل غدا
اقتحام انصار الرئيس اليمني السابق جير
بورسونارو مقر عدد من مؤسسات الحكم في
العاصمه البرازيليه وهو ما وصفه اليوم
بيان مشترك للرئيس البرازيلي ورؤساء
الكونجرس والمحكمه العليا بالاعمال
الارهابيه والتخريبيه والاجراميه
والانقلابيه لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
ما هي ابرز عوامل فشل مساعد الاطاحه بنظام
الحكم في البرازيل من قبل انصار الرئيس
السابق اما اجاباتكم فقد جاءت على نحو
الاتي
58% قالوا ان السبب هو عدم تاييدها من قبل
الجيش وقال 29% الى السبب هو التمسك
بالتجربه الديمقراطيه بينما اعاده 13% الى
الخوف من اقصى اليمين
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الظاهري اعلى الشاشه
لقائد الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربي ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد احتفالات بتحرير الاسير كريم يونس بن
جرير يامر بمنع رفع العلم الفلسطيني
والتلويح به
[موسيقى]
يتواصلوا القتال في شرقي اوكرانيا ويقول
الجيش الاوكراني ان مدينه
النقطه الاكثر سخونه على الجبهه حيث يدور
قتال عنيف ومع استمرار المعارك ذكرت
تقارير صحفيه ان بريطانيا
بالدبابات لاول مره من اجل مساعدتها في
التصدي للقوات الروسيه ومن الكريم جاء
الرد تسليم اوكرانيا
واسلحه اخرى لن يغيره
يتصاعد القتال في اوكرانيا ويتصاعد ايذاءه
الحديث عن تكثيف الدعم الغربي منذ الاحد
يتحدث الجانب الروسي عن معارك عنيفه
يخوضها في مدينه سوليدار شمالي دونيتسك
وعن خسائر فادحه تكبدها الاوكرانيون
ابرزها سقوط بلده بخمود سكوين
والاوكرانيون من جهتهم ارسلوا تعزيزات
لمدينه سوليدار وقالوا ان الجيش الروسي
قصفها خلال الساعات الماضيه اكثر من 100
مره وشنف 22 هجوما سعيا الاقتحامها وفقا
ناطق الاوكراني باسم قياده المنطقه
الشرقيه فقد دمرت مدينه السوليدار بشكل
جزئي نتيجه الهجمات الروسيه الاخيره بعد
ان زوجه موسكو باكثر عناصر فاجنر خبره
وتدريبا وحددتني نقاط ضعف الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه وضغطت عليها
يكفي فرصه اذا ضغطهم على جبهات القتال وفي
المقابل تتعالى دعوات غربيه للاحتشاد خلف
اوكرانيا هذه المره بتقديم اعتاد هجوميه
تدعو بولندا لتشكيل التحالف واسع لتزويج
اوكرانيا بالدبابات القتاليه الحديثه لعله
استعداد لحمله واسعه يواصل المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون التبشير بها كمغير مرتب وجذري
للموازين الميدانيه تحدثت اطراف مغربيه
عده عن امدادات للدبابات والمدرعات للحديث
الاوكراني تدرس بريطانيا تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات قتاليه من طراز شالنجر اثنين التي
تزن اثنين وستين طنا ونصف الطن ومزوده
بمدفع معيار 120 ملمترا وكانت الولايات
المتحده اعلنت قبل ايام عن تقديم مساعدات
العسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا تتضمن عربات
قتاليه امريكيه من طراز برادلي التي تزن
اكثر من سبعه وعشرين من ومزوده بمدفع من
عيار 25 ملم وصواريخ خارقه للدروع ويمكن
ان تعمل كناقله جند كما اعلنت فرنسا ارسال
مركبات قتاليه مدرعه خفيفه من طراز اي ام
اكس 10 ار سي المزوده بمدفع من عيار 150
ملم والتي تسير على عجلات مما يجعلها سهله
الحركه وكذلك يناقش المسؤولون في المانيا
امداد كيف بدبابات قتاليه ومدرعات من طراز
ماردر التي يبلغ عيار مدفعها الاوتوماتيكي
25 ملليمترا يقلل الرسل من اهميه هذه
الامدادات العسكريه الغربيه لاوكرانيا
ويرونها لن تكون قادره على اي تغيير جذريا
لكن السكرتيره مجلس الامن الروسي كولاي
باترون شيف يضيفه ان بلاده لا تحاربه
اوكرانيه بالهيه في مواجهه الان مع نيته
وعلى راسه الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وهو
حلف اتهمه المسؤول الروسي باستهدا اضعاف
بلاده وتدمير هذه اي ثمن على المدى البعيد
مديره السياسيه في حلف الناتسابقا ومن
موسكو اندري فلوڤ الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بكما سيد فابريس بوتي
على اي اساس يمكن ان تزود الدول الداعمه
اللي اوكرانيا اوكرانيا بمزيد من الاسلحه
النوعيه
تدافع عن نفسها والماده الحاديه والخمسين
من ميثاق الامم المتحده تقفل ذلك اوكرانيا
تدافع عن اراضيها التي غزتها القوات
الروسيه واوكرانيا تدافع عن الشعب
الاوكراني وعن سياده اوكرانيا وفقا لميثاق
الامم المتحده وفقا لهذا الاساس مجموعه من
الدول في كل انحاء العالم وليس فقط من ضمن
خلف شمال الاطلسي دول حتى من اسيا انضمت
الى هذا الجهد لدعم اوكرانيا على المستوى
السياسي والعسكري
حياه لا تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه هجوميه
اليوم يتم الحديث عن امكانيه تزويدها
بدبابات النوعيه على اي اساس جار هذا
التحول
استنى اساس هذا التحول هو ان ما رايناه
منذ العاشر
كبير من قبل القوات الروسيه التي لم تتوقف
عند
الهجوم على القوات الاوكرانيه في ميدان
المعركه بل انها تطلق الصواريخ التي
تستهدف المدنيين والبنى تحتيه الحيويه
المدنيه وبالتالي الرد الوحيد من جانب
التحالف الدولي هو بتزويد اوكرانيا متقدمه
من الاسلحه لكي تتمكن القوات الاوكرانيه
من الدفاع عن الشعب الاوكراني بشكل افضل
عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه كذلك ذلك
الاسلحه لن تحدث سارقا في ميزان القوى
ستروبري كاظم
صحيح لان الحمله ذا فويس
روسيا من التهديدات الاوكرانيه وفقا
لميثاق الامم المتحده ولذلك عندما نتحدث
عن القدرات العسكريه هذه القدرات العسكريه
ليست كبيره بشكل
يغير
ميزان القوه لصالح اوكرانيا نعم هذه
المعدات العسكريه تشكل وتهديدات
لروسيا وسوف تؤدي الى الحاقه الاضرار
بالقوات الروسيه ولكن لا اعتقد ان من
شانها ان تغير الوضع الميداني لكي يصبح
لصالح اوكرانيا
العسكريه التي تصل الى اوكرانيا تاخر من
تقدم القوات الروسيه مثال على ذلك ما يحدث
اخمد الجاري فيها القتال منذ الصيف حتى في
بعض الاحيان تجبرها على تجبر القوات
الروسيه على الانسحاب اذا هي تغير
صحيح لانه وفقا للتقارير الاخيره القوات
الروسيه احتلت نصف مدينه سوليدار
وايضا في ضخمات نفسها
عن حق يمكننا ان نقول ان القوات الروسيه
في المرحله الراهنه لديها الالفضاليه في
مواجهه القوات الاوكرانيه والمبادره في
الميدان هي لصالح روسيا
من الاسلحه حتى لو كانت نوعيه الى
اوكرانيا هو حل باعتقادك وباعتقادك ووفقه
وجهه نظر الدول الداعمه لاوكرانيا ام انه
يجدر البحث عن حلول اخرى ربما لوقف هذه
الحرب
اشعار اخر
الحل هو عسكري
والسبب بسيط روسيا غير مهتمه بسلامه
حقيقيه وبمفاوضات تؤدي الى سلام حقيقي بل
على العكس روسيا تودوا ان تضغط بشكل ضخم
على اوكرانيا وتحاول روسيا وهذا ما تحاول
ان تقوم به الان بالتحديد من خلال القصف
الجوي والصاروخي تودد روسيا ان تكسر اراده
الشعب الاوكراني لذلك الرد الوحيد اليوم
هو في الجبهه العسكريه وحتى تتمكن
اوكرانيا من تحقيق موقفا جيدا في ميدان
المعركه لا اعتقد ان المفاوضات يمكن ان
تجري بشكل صحيح
حتى تحقق مكاسب ميدانيه مهمه تعطيها طليه
في الميدان
الحظ هذا يعني ان هناك
ضحايا من اوساطي الجيش الاوكراني والشعب
الاوكراني هذا ما سوف يؤدي اليه
هذا الحال اذا هذا يعطي امل ان لا تتفاوض
مع روسيا وبالتالي لسوء الحظ هذه المعدات
العسكريه
مش الروسي ويقول لك تقول الدول الغربيه
الداعمه لاوكرانيا ان كل ذلك بسبب الهجوم
الروسي
ضحايا في الجانب الروسي ولكن القياده في
روسيا وخصوصا الرئيس كرر ان روسيا تود ان
تستمر بهذه العمليه حتى يتم اجتثاث النزيه
من همم من اوكرانيا
يقولون ان تزويد اوكرانيا بكل هذه الاسلحه
النوعيه دليل على ان ما تقوله روسيا منذ
اليوم الاول ان المواجهه ليست فقط مع
اوكرانيا ولكن مع الدول التي تقف خلفه ما
رايك بهذا الكلام
الروسيه تحاول ان
تشتت انتباهها العالم عن الفشل الذريه
الذي لحق بالقوات الروسيه وعلى عكسي ما
تفضل به الضيف الاخر ان روسيا هي من تسبب
باصابه اعداد كبيره من اعضاء القوات
الروسيه
لاهداف مشكوكا هذا يجب ان يطرح السؤال
لماذا تخاطر روسيا بحياه 100,000 عنصر في
القوات الروسيه اللي همم
يتم الشفافه النازيه من بلد كما تقول هي
ولكن من بلد لم يشكل اي تهديد لروسيا
تاريخيا لذلك اوكرانيا والشعب الاوكراني
هو من عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه اما القوات
الروسيه فهي تدافع عن مشروع رجل واحد
والاشخاص المحيطين به ولذلك التحالف
الدولي يرسل رساله واضحه داعمه بشكل كبير
لاوكانيا
العسكريه الغربيه لاوكرانيا ونسال خبيرا
عسكريا عن تاثيرها المحتمل في ميزان القوى
[موسيقى]
بالاجماع وافق اعضاء مجلس الامن الدولي
على تمديد اليه ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
الى ملايين السوريين من خلال معبر باب
الهوى على الحدود مع تركيا مده التمديد
سته اشهر في وقت يعاني فيه اكثر من اثنين
عشره مليون سوري انعدام الامن الغذائي
ويتفشى وباء الكوليرا في البلد
[__]
[موسيقى]
بدون عراقيل عشيه انتهاء التفويض وفق
اعضاء مجلس الامن الدولي بالاجماع على
الاستمرار في تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
عبر الحدود الى سوريا
الى ملايين السوريين النازحين من ديارهم
لم يكن الوضع الانساني
في سبتمبر العمل الماضي بينما تحدثت تقرير
عن احد عشر الف اصابه في حلب
وكان مجلس الامن الدولي قد اجاز في عام
2014 ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى مناطق
تسيطر عليها فصائل المعارضه في سوريا من
العراق والاردن ونقطتين في تركيا لكن
موسكو بيجين قلصت ذلك الى نقطه حدوديه
واحده هي معبر باب الهوى مع تركيا في شمال
غرب سوريا يسمح تفويض الامم المتحده
للوكالات الاغاثيه باحضار مستلزمات
النظافه واقراص الكلور لتعقيم المياه
والمعدات
لثمانيه مراكز علاج الكوليرا ويحدث ان
تنقل بعض المنظمات غير الحكوميه المياه
النظيفه الى المنازل بعد اثنا عشر عاما من
الحرب غالبيه الشعب تعيش اليوم تحت خط
الفقر يعاني اكثر من اثني عشر مليون سوري
انعدام الامن الغذائي والظروفا معيشيه
قاسيه جدا الازمه الانسانيه المستمر في
سوريا رغم مساعدات لا يمكن الاستغناء عنها
وحسابات سياسيه اقليميه والدوليه معقده
وكثيره التفويض الاممي يجدد كل سته اشهر
وليس كل سنه وقبل تاريخ انتهاء التفويض
والاستعداد للتصويت من اجل تمديده
يحبس الملايين انفاسهم خشيه فيتو يفقم
الوضع الانساني المتدهور
جلسه مجلس الامن شهد التصريحات من
المندوبه الامريكيه ليندا
رحبت فيها بالقرار لكنها قالت انه كان
ينبغي تجديد الاليه لمده عام لا لمده سته
اشهر فقط
اتفضل
الامم المتحده بحاجه الى تمديد الاليه
لمده 12 شهرا وهذا ضروري لشركائنا في
المجال الانساني والمستفيدين هذا القرار
يمثل الحد الادنى النقاش الذي نحتاج اليه
هو كيفيه تعزيز الاليه لضمان وصول
المساعدات الى المزيد من الاشخاص في
الاشهر المقبله يجب ان نظهر للشعب السوري
اننا سنستمر في وضع انسانيته اولا لانه في
الوقت الحالي الاحتياجات في جميع انحاء
سوريا من الشمال الغربي الى الشمال الشرقي
وفي جميع محافظاتها اكبر من ما كانت عليه
في اي وقت مضى
في جانب اخر وصف مندوب روسيا غسيل نبنزا
قرار التجديد بالصعب مضيفا انه لا ينبغي
اعتبار الخطوه تغييرا في موقف موسكو مبدئي
من الاليه كما اشار الى ان العقوبات هي
العامل الرئيسي وراء التدهور الوضع
الانساني في سوريا
الى سوريا وتتجنب قضيه اخرى مزعجه للغايه
وهي العقوبات الاحاديه التي تؤثر سلبا على
السوريين العاديين هذه العقوبات هي العامل
الرئيسي وراء تدهور الوضع الانساني في
سوريا تعمل الدول الغربيه عن قصد لضمان
تفاقم الوضع وتسعه جاهده لوقف عمليه تطبيع
الوضع في البلاد الى اقصى حد لتشويه جهود
الحكومه الشرعيه
ينضم الينا من ادلب عبد الرزاق عوض مدير
منظمه سيريا ريليف او الاغاثه السوريه
مرحبا بك سيد عبد الرزاق عوض ما الفرق
ايتم تجديد هذا التفويض لسته اشهر بدل من
سنه كيف يؤثر ذلك على عملكم
في الحقيقه يؤثر
التمديد ومدد التمديد من سته اشهر الى سنه
على اعمالنا بوضع الخطط
با اليه تنفيذ المشاريع يعني نحن اليوم
همم
نركز بشكل كامل على المشاريع الطارئه خلال
سته اشهر لا يمكننا ابدا ان نفكر في هذه
المرحله بمشاريع التعافي المبكر لان
مشاريع التعافي المبكر التخطيط لها على
الاقل يستغرق ثلاثه اشهر واكثر هذا اهم
عامل يعني نحتاجه نحن همم يكون التسديد
عباره عن سنه عوضا عن ثلاثه عن سته اشهر
بالاضافه الى اننا قبل همم يعني انتهاء
مده تفويض السته اشهر بشهر او شهرين يعني
نحن نغلق المشاريع الخاصه بالامم المتحده
ويعني نكون همم على متوقين تماما استجابات
ولا متوقفه تماما همم حتى تجديد
وحتى همم الاذن من قبل مجلس الامن بتفويض
همم بالتفويض الجديد لادخال المساعدات عبر
الحدود هذا لا يعطينا الوقت الكافي لا
للتخطيط لمشاريع جديده سنبقى في سياق
المشاريع الطارئه سنبقى في سياق
الاستجابات العاجله فقد لا يمكننا التفكير
ولا التخطيط مع الامم المتحده ومع
الشركائنا همم الدوليين في ومع الداعمين
الدوليين في مشاريع التعافي المبكر التي
اليوم نحتاجها اليوم في سوريا اكثر هذه
همم يحتاجها اللاجئون السوريون ولا يمكن
تنفيذها الا في اطار تفويض على مدار عام
هذه المشاريع التي تتعلق بالبنيه التحتيه
لاكثر من مليون شخص يعني
للمخيمات التي يقتلها اكثر من مليون شخص
هذه البنيه التحتيه تحتاج نقل ال ال
الاهالي والنازحين القاطنين في خيام محتري
اليوم يعانيهم في فصل الشتاء اقصى الظروف
نحتاج نقلهم الى همم الى
يعني اراضي ومخيمات ذات بني تحتيه صالحه
ذات تتوفر فيها الخدمات الاساسيه
تتوفر فيها وصول لمياه الشرب النقيه في ظل
انتشار وباء الكوليرا هذه المشاريع هذه
اهم المشاريع التي نقصدها ايضا المشاريع
التي تؤمن للعوائل داخل الثابت ومستقر
مشاريع العمل المال مقابل العمل الم-
افتتاح بعض المشاريع الصغيره لهؤلاء
النازحين في اماكن سكننهم هذه المشاريع
التي نقصدها تحتاج التخطيط لها اكثر من
اربعه اشهر وتنفيذها يعني على الاقل يحتاج
الى عام او هذا ما يحتاجه اليوم عبد
الرزاق بديلا عن المشاريع الاستجابه
الطارئه التي نعمل عليها
التي تعملون عليها ما هو الان اا يعني في
صداره جدول اعمالكم بالنسبه للمرحله
المقبله ما هي ابرز الاحتياجات الطارئه
حاليا للاجئين
في الحقيقه تخوفاتنا من عدم كانت من عدم
تسجيل قرار مساعدات عبر الحدود كانت تتركز
بشكل رئيسي على ثلاثه قطاعات اولها الصحه
وفي راسها الصحه وفي ظل يعني خروجنا من
رائحه كورونا ودخولنا في همم انتشار وباء
الكوليرا وهذا ما يعني بشكل رئيسي في
المخيمات القطاع الثاني وهو القطاع همم
يعني
التقديم الخدمات المياه والاصحاح في
المخيمات ايضا همم القطاع الثالث وهو قطاع
التعليم وهو القطاع المهم جدا الذي نحتاجه
هو ايضا القطاع الامن الغذائي هذه
المساعدات الغذائيه التي تتصل عبر الحدود
يحتاجها الى الان ولا تغطي حتى في ظل همم
يعني التفويض الحاصل لا تغطي اكثر من 60%
من النازحين القاتلين في الخيام في شمال
غرب سوريا تركيزنا بشكل رئيسي في مشاريع
يعني خلال هذه سته اشهر وحتى الست اشهر
التي قبلها يكون فقط
اهلينا في المخيمات في حين نحن نحتاج اكثر
لمدد للتخطيط ولمشاريع التعافي المبشره
عوض
الاغاثه السوريه ضيفنا من ادلب
ما هي اليه وادخال المساعدات الى سوريا
متى اعتمدت وكيف تعمل وما المعابر التي
تمر منها المساعدات المعنيه بهذه الاليه
وفقا للقرار رقم
2156 لعام 2014
هي باب السلامه وباب الهواء وهما على
الحدود السوريه التركيه وليعربيه عند
الحدود السوريه العراقيه والرمثا على
الحدود مع الاردن لكن القرار رغم 2,500
2004 الصادر عام 2020 خلص المعابر الى
الاثنين وهما باب الهوى وباب السلامه
ولمده سته اشهر فقط بينما اغلق معبره
اليعربيه مع العراق والرمثا مع الاردن بعد
ذلك اقتصر القرار رقم
2533 لعام 2020 على معبر واحد هو باب
الهوى القرار التالي ابقى معبر باب الهوى
واضافه ادخال المساعدات عبر خطوط التماس
اي من مناطق النظامي الى مناطق المعارضه
[موسيقى]
الى الشان السودانيه حيث قال المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده ستيفان دو
جريك انا انطونيو جوتياريش يرحب باطلاق
المرحله النهائيه من العمليه السياسيه نحو
استعاده انتقال الديمقراطي بقياده المدنيه
في السودان اضاف دورجريك ان المنظمه
الدوليه لا تزال ملتزمه بدعم العمليات
السياسيه والمساعده في انجاز اتفاق
النهائيا في السودان خلال الاسابيع
المقبله
نيشن
سوريات الثلاثيه التي تتالف من بعثه الامم
المتحده المتكامله للمساعده الانتقاليه في
السودان والاتحاد الافريقي والهيئه
الحكوميه الدوليه المهنيه بالتنميه ملتزمه
بدعم العمليه والمساعده في تامين اتفاق
سياسي نهائي خلال الاسابيع المقبله لضمان
تسويه دائما يؤكد الامين العام على اهميه
الاشراك اوسع مجموعه من اصحاب المصلحه
السودانيين بمن في ذلك النساء والشباب
والمجتمع المدني كما يحث اصحاب المصلحه
الرئيسيين الذين لم يوقعوا على اتفاق
الخامس من ديسمبر على الانضمام الى
العمليه السياسيه واخيرا يجدد على اهميه
الدعم الدولي
والمنسق للعمليه السياسيه في اطار الاليه
الثلاثيه
وباشراف الاليه الثلاثيه بدات الاحزاب
السياسيه السودانيه بحث سبل التوصل الى
اتفاق النهائيا بشان تشكيل حكومه مدنيه
وحل قضايا عالقه اخرى تندرج في سياق
المرحله النهائيه انطلاقا من الاتفاق
الايطالي وتتناول الاجتماعات قضايا
تفصيليه ضمن الاتفاق الواقع الشهر الماضي
ظلت عالقه مثل صياغه الفصل الخاص لتفتيك
نظام 30 من يونيو وكان رئيس مجلس السياده
الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان قد تعهد بخروج
الجيش من المشهد السياسي والمرحله
الانتقاليه من جهتها ابدى نائب رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني الفريق محمد حمدان حميد
في امله في التحاق المجموعات المعارضه
بالحوار
قال القيادي في قوى الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي ورئيس المكتب السياسي لحزب
الامه القومي محمد المهدي حسن ان الخلافات
بشان الاتفاق الايطالي تتعلق بما وصفها
بابعاد شخصيه لرافدي الاتفاق اضافه الى
بعض القضايا الاجرائيه اضاف ان المرحله
المقبله من الاتصالات ستشارك فيها جميع
مكونات السودان
لا اعتقد ان هنالك خلاف كبير لانهم هذه
القضايا التي
تضمنها الانتفاخ الايطار هي القضايا
الشارع السوداني قضايا الشعب السوداني
قضاء الثوره السودانيه ولذلك فقدت الامر
متعلق بامور بسيطه جدا فيها بعد همم شخص
ويقول هذا الكلام وانا مسؤول عنه وكذلك
فيها بعد قضايا اجرائيه
بدوره يعتبر القياده في قوى الحريه
والتغيير الكتله الديمقراطيه عبد العزيز
سليمان ان المطلوبه في هذه المرحله في
السودان هو معالجه جذور الازمه التاريخيه
للبلاد حسب تعبيره اضاف سليمان ان
الانتقال الثالث لابد ان يستند على توافق
جميع المكونات المدنيه والمسلحه
الجذور الازمه السودانيه اولا ومن ثم
يشارك الجميع حتى يحضروا عشان نعسس لفتره
الانتقاليه السادسه ويكون في تحول
ديمغرافي حقيقي وبالتالي نقدر نضمن جميعنا
همم ننزل في الانتخابات هره ونذيعه
من جهه قال السفير والنرويجي في السودان
ممثل الوساطه الدوليه
اندروستيانسن في مقابله مع الجزيره انه
يؤمن بان الجيش السوداني سينفذ تعاهداته
ويعود الى سكناته
الى سكناته وان دوره الاساسي سيكون
التامين البلاد والابتعاد عن الحكومه
المدنيه نحن نؤمن ونعتقد انهم سيوفون
بعهدهم في الوضع خطير جدا وهم يدركون ما
يجري في البلاد ولذلك سيكوننا جزءا من
الحل الجنرال البرهان كان واضحا فيما تم
الخوض فيه امس هذا هو جوهر الاتفاق
الايطالي ولا يمكن لاحد ان وضع ضمانات
ينضم الينا من واشنطن تمسيكارنيا السفير
الامريكي السابق في السودان مرحبا بك
سعاده السفير ثم في كورني كيف تابعت
انطلاق المرحله النهائيه من هذه العمليه
السياسيه الجاريه الان في السودان
اليوم هناك فقدان كبير للثقه بين
المتظاهرين المدنيين وبين القوات المسلحه
وكما تفضلتم في المقدمه عدد من
الهيئات السياسيه والقوى السياسيه لم تنضم
الى الاتفاق الايطالي الذي وقع في السابق
تشكي
القوات المسلحه ونوايا السيد البرهان
بالنسبه الى اعتقد ان المشككين يتعين
عليهم ان يحدد بعض النقاط المرجعيه اذا ما
توصلت اليها القوات المسلحه اذا ما توصل
اليها الجيش السوداني اذا ما توصل الى
تنفيذها يعني ذلك انه يعمل بنيه حسنه
والب الاول على الاجنده اليوم ما الذي
يمكن ان يتم
لتفكيك
تبيعات سنوات البشير هذه نقطه انطلاق يبدو
انها جيده
عدم انضمام بعض هذه المجموعات التي تحدثت
عنها عدم انضمها الى الاتفاق الاطاري
وبالتالي الى هذه العمليه السياسيه
واستمرارها على هذا الموقف فيما لو استمر
باعتقادك كيف من شانها ان يؤثر على مخرجات
هذه المشاورات الجاريه الان
مجددا
نقطه الرئيسه هي انه يتعين على كل هذه
المجموعات في نهايه المطاف ان تتخذ القرار
بالانضمام الى العمليه السياسيه ولا يمكن
ان يتم ذلك الا في حال اقتنعت بان العمليه
هي بالفعل جدي وسوف تاتي بالفائده للسودان
وسوف تؤدي بالفعل نفسه الى حياه السياسيه
ديمقراطيه مدنيه والجيش يعود الى التقنيه
ما مصير المشاورات الجاريه الان باعتقادك
افتحي
حال لم تقرر هذه القوى الانضمام الى
المباحثات سوف تشكل مجموعه
خارج النتيجه الحاليه التي يتم التوصل
اليها وهذا يمكن ان يؤدي الى استمرار
زعزعه الاستقرار في السودان هذا امر لا
يطمح اليه اي من اصحاب المصلحه في السودان
ويتعين على كل الفرقاء ان يعملوا على حل
هذه المشكله هي نقطه مهمه بالنسبه الى
الوضع الراهن شكرا لك
السابق في السودان
[موسيقى]
الى البرازيل حيث عرضت وسائل الاعلام
برازيليه صورا لعمليات تفتيش تقوم بها
قوته الامن الاعتصام انصار الرئيس السابق
جرير سونارو المقابر بالقرب من مقر الجيش
في العاصمه البرازيليه وبين ما استدعت
السلطات قوات اضافيه الى العاصمه تواصل
قوته الامن فضعتصام مؤيدين بالسونارو
وتنقلهم في حافلات تابعه للحكومه تمهيدا
لمقاضاتهم وابقى وسائل الاعلام برازيليه
جاء ذلك غدا اقتحام انصار الرئيس
البرازيلي السابق جرير بولسونارو مقر
حكوميه في العاصمه البرازيليه في تطور نفى
بوسونار تورطه فيه وكان الرئيس البرازيلي
يولد سيلفا ورئيس المحكمه العليا
والكونغرس قد وصفوا الاقتحامات بالعمل
الارهابي في حين امر الادعاء العام
باعتقال وزير الامن العام
ريه البرازيليه قد تهشمت وتحطم معها
التداول السلمي للسلطه بعد ما خلفه اقتحام
مراكز الحكم في العاصمه برازيليه حسب
انصار الرئيس الولد سيلفا خراب ودمار
كبيران لحقاب القصر الرئاسي بعد اقتحامه
من قبل محتاجين في سابقه تاريخيه
الخراب طال مبنى المحكمه الفيدراليه
العليا ايضا التي اقتحمت مع مبنى البرلمان
من قبل مؤيد رئيس اليمني السابق جرير
الرافدين لعوده الزعيم اليسري الى الحكم
ده سيلفا الذي لم يكن في القصر ساعه
الاقتحام تواعد من ساو باولو بمحاسبه
منفذي الهجوم ووصفه بالهمجي والفاشي
سيتم توقيفه ومحاسبه المشاركين بهذا الفعل
الهمجي ليعرف جيدا ان الديمقراطيه التي
وجدت لحمايه حق التعبير لديها الياتها
لحمايه مؤسساتها التي تصوم الديمقراطيه
المقيم في الولايات المتحده فسارع في
سلسله تغريدات الى نفي علاقته باقتحام
انصاره واصفا اياه بتجاوز القاعده وهكذا
فعل حاكم المقاطعه الفيدراليه الذي قدم
اعتذاره للرئيس لولا وقال وزير الامن
المحلي للعاصمه اعتذار قبل بالرفض حيث
اوقفته المحكمه العليا عن العمل لمده 90
يوما في اطار تحقيقات اعلن عن بدائها وزير
الداخليه والقضايا البرازيلي مؤكدا تنفيذ
امر رئاسي باستدعاء القوات الفدرا لبسط
الامن
والديمقراطيه نؤكد ان الامر لا يتعلق
بالانتخابات هذا ارهاب وانقلاب
تمكنت تلك القوه اخيرا من باص سيطرتها على
عاصمه صممت مبانيها الحكميه دون اسوار
وساحاتها مفتوحه دون ابواب لتغلق بعد 60
عاما عقبا كلاب الاحوال كما يقول ابن
العاصمه في النار
لما تخيل ان ارى العاصمه هكذا يوما تغيرت
الاحوال كثيرا وبات الوضع مؤثرا
بعدما باتت ساحه السلطات مسرح مواجهات
وقصر الشعب مكانا للشغب وصل الانقسام
البرازيلي حسب البعض الى ابعد حد ورغم
استعاده السيطره على مركز الحكم فان عوده
الزعيم اليساري الاولى دا سيلفا اليه لن
تمر على ما يبدو دون عقبات حسن مسعود
الجزيره برازيليه
السابق ادخل المستشفى في ولايه فلوريدا
الامريكيه اسرائيليه في البطن قال مستشار
الامن القومي
الاداره الامريكيه لم تتلقى طلبا من
الحكومه البرازيليه يتعلق بوضع بولسونار
القانوني مشيرا الى اداره الامريكيه ليست
على اتصال مباشر به ولذلك لا يمكن تحديده
مكان وجوده اضاف ان ديمقراطيه في البرازيل
قويه
وستقاوم الاحداث التي جرت مؤخرا
ينضم الينا من سوفول وعلي فرحات الخبير في
الشان البرازيلي مرحبا بك سيد علي ما ابرز
الاستنتاجات التي يمكن الخروج بها مما حدث
بالامس
مساء الخير
البرازيليه مازالت قويه ان اغلبيه المجتمع
البرازيلي لا يؤيد العنف هو يعترض في بعض
الاماكن يؤيد في بعض الاماكن لكن ما
رايناه اليوم من اجتماعات بين قاده
وبالمناسبه القادمه من مشارب سياسيه
مختلفه حيث اكدوا جميعهم على رفض العنف
على رفض قلب النتيجه الديمقراطيه وبالتالي
اعتقد ان البرازيل حتى الان قد نجحت في
اختبار الديمقراطيه وعاده الامور الى
نصابها اليوم على ان تستكمل التحقيقات
لكشف من المتورط في هذا العمل التخريبي
الكبير الذي تعرفه
الذي يقال ما هي الى من تشير اصابع
الاتهام الاليه ان كان الرئيس السابقين في
تحريضه على هذه الاحداث
عماليه موثوقه بان التحقيقات تضع اسم
جيرمان على راس اللائحه لكن لم يتم
الاعلان حتى الان عن هذا الامر بينما هناك
ايضا تحقيقات ستطال بعض رجال الاعمال بعد
السياسيين وايضا بعض الاعلاميين الذين
حرضوا في الايام المقبله والذين كان لهم
النصيب في التخطيط من اجل القيام بهذا
الامر صحيح ان هناك الكثير من من يتنصلون
الان لكن كما قال همم قاضي المحكمه العليا
للشمس هناك محاسبه ستكون قريبا جدا وسيكون
هناك تكشف للتحقيقات وشفافيه في اعلام
الاسماء ماذا عن ما يقال بشان همم طريقه
تعامل الجيش والقوى الامنيه مع ما حدث
سواء ما سبق يعني مرحله التخطيط لهذه
عمليه الاقتحامات واثناء عمليه الاقتحام
المغلقه لماذا لم تقوم الشرطه العسكريه
بمهامها في المنطقه لماذا لم حكومه
الولايه لم تتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه اللي
هي ضعف المسؤوليه ام هل هو تواطئ في هذا
الامر فيما يصل يتصل بالجيش هناك التباس
كبير جدا بموقف الجيش حتى الان لم يعطي
موقفا اذا هذا الموضوع وهذا مثير جدا
للجدل على كل الاحوال الرئيس البرازيلي
اعلن حاله التاهب العسكري او الدخول
العسكري الى العاصمه الجيش الان موجود به
ان يقرر وان يعلن موقفه من هذا الامر
خصوصا وان الضغوط الداخليه والخارجيه باتت
لا تسمح بمواقف ضبابيه ومواقف غير معينه
في المرحله المقبله مع جاريثونار وهو
موجود في الولايات المتحده كيف يمكن
للرئيس دوله سيلفا ان يق هذه المساله في
ظل التوازنات الدقيقه في داخل الحكومه
نتائج التحقيق لعل الدائره الضيقه
لبوسنارو ستكون الان على راس الشبهات
وبالتالي موضوع من سونار وقد يطول قليلا
لانه خارج البلاد ولان الادله الان لا
تثبت تورطه بشكل مباشر على الرغم من صلته
غير المباشره بهذه الاحداث لكن دعيني اقول
لك بان اسماء المقربه جدا من بور سونارو
كانت تقف معه على نفس اللي يعني في
الاحتفالات وفي الحملات الانتخابيه قد
تكون متورطه في هذا الامر وهي التي مولت
هذا الامر وهناك اسماء اصبحت لدى القضاه
اسماء واضحه جراء اعتراف عدد من الذين قبض
عليهم ليله امس برازيلي
[موسيقى]
استدعى الاتحاد الاوروبي ممثلين ايران
الدبلوماسيين لديه احتجاجا على التظاهرات
التي تشهدها البلاد منذ منتصف سبتمبر
الماضي و رفضا لتنفيذ حكمين جديدين
بالاعدام واستدعى وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
القائمه بالاعمال الايراني الاحتجاج على
احكام جديده بالاعدام في حق متظاهرين كما
اعلنت الخارجيه الفرنسيه انها استدعت
القائمه بالاعمال الايراني في باريس
للاحتجاج على عمليات الاعدام وحمله القمع
في ايران حسب بيان صادرا عن الوزاره
امر وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ايتامار
بن جري الشرطه الاسرائيليه بمنع رفع العلم
الفلسطيني والتلويح به في الداخل
الفلسطيني وقال ان قراره ياتي لمنع ما
سماه التماهي مع منظمه ارهابيه حسب تعبيره
تقارير اعلاميه اسرائيليه اشارت الى توتر
بين بني كبير وشرطه الاحتلال بعد احتفالات
بخروج الاسير كريم يونس في بلده عاره رفع
خلالها العلم الفلسطيني قرار بني كثير سبق
جلسه مرتقبه للكنيسه الاسرائيلي لاقرار
تعديلات تجيز سحب الجنسيه من اسرى فلسطيني
الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي توصف بانها
الاكثر تطرفا وتشددا تفتح باب المخاوف على
مزيد من الاجراءات ضد الفلسطينيين في
قرارات ترتبط بشكل اساسي بالداخل
الفلسطينيين داخل المحتل من البقاء في
ارضهم وترحيلهم كسرا وهو ما يضعه
الفلسطينيون في مربع محاولات اسرائيل
اخلاء المدني من سكانها وفي اطار السياسات
الائتلاف الحاكم المتطرف امر وزير الامن
القومي تمر الشرطه الاسرائيليه لمنع رفع
العالم الفلسطيني والتلويح به مصنفا الامر
كدعم لمنظمه الارهابيه علما ان الامر
خاضعا من قبل بتقدير قاده المناطق في
الشرطه الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
عوده الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث دخل
الدعم العسكري الغربي لكيف مستويات
النوعيه غير مسبوقه من الدبابات والاسلحه
الثقيله المتطوره فقد اورد التقارير
اعلاميه غربيه ان بريطانيا تخطط لارسال
دبابات من طراز شالنجر اثنين الى اوكرانيا
لمساعدتها في التصدي للهجمات الروسيه
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه اكدت ان لندن
قدمت اوكرانيا حتى الان اكثر من 200 مركبه
مدرعه من بينها انظمه دفاع جوي من طرازي
ستورمر والاسبوع الماضي اعلانات الحكومه
الالمانيه انا ستسلم اوكرانيا 40 ناقله
جند مدرعه من طراز مارتن بينما تلحوا كيف
في تزويدها الدبابات لا برد اثنان
المتطوره لكن الامر ما زال قيد النقاش في
برلين وقررت الولايات المتحده تزويده
اوكرانيا بمدرعاته ليه وناقلات جندا مدرعه
ومدافعها ذاتيه الدفع وصواريخ هاي مارس
الدقيقه وصواريخ سيسبارو المضاده للطائرات
اما فرنسا فكانت اول دوله غربيه توافق على
تسليم اوكرانيا دبابات خفيفه من طراز اي
ام اكس 10 ار سي وهي مركباته قتال المدرعه
بدا تصنيعها في ثمانينيات القرن الماضي
ومزوده بمدفع من عيار 150 م
مقابل الاسلحه الموعوده كانت اوكرانيا قد
تسلمت بالفعل اسلحه النوعيه مختلفه اسهمت
في اعاده توجيه مسار المعارك
لصالحكاف ومن ابرزها منظومه هاي مارس
الامريكيه التي تسلمتها اوكرانيا في يونيو
الماضي وهي راجمات صواريخ دقيقه التوجيه
تحمل واحده منها سته صواريخ كما حصلت
اوكرانيا في مارس الماضي على صواريخ
ستينجر الامريكيه المضاده للطائرات وهي
صواريخ محموله على الكتف وتفوق سرعتها
سرعه الصوت كما زودت الولايات المتحده
اوكرانيا في نهايه فبراير الماضي بمدافع
حول ذاتي اعيره مختلفه تطلق تطلق قذائف
دقيقه التوجيه على اهدافها ام لا اول
والاسلحه النوعيه لاوكرانيا فكانت صواريخ
جافا الامريكيه المضادات
وقد بدات تسليمها الحرب وتحديدا في ديسمبر
عام 2001 و20 حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك لواء فايز
دويري
باعتقادك كيف من شان الدبابات التي يجري
دراسه تسليمها الى اوكرانيا من قبل
بريطانيا الان ان تغير في موازين القوى
[موسيقى]
من المعدات هي مصممه اصلا
للادوار التعرضيه الهجوميه ولكن يمكن
استخدامها في الادوار الدفاعيه وبالتالي
هذا يعتبر تجاوز للخطوط الحمراء اي في
البدايه كان فقط لتمكين الجيش الاوكراني
من الدفاع عن نفسه ضد الهجمات الروسيه
الان لا ستزود وتم الاقرار وهناك بحث ما
بين بولندا والمانيا من اجل الدبابات
الثقيله اذا دعيني اقول هو تجاوز الخطوط
الحمراء وهذا يعني الشيء الكثير لكن ماذا
ستقدم ماذا ستقدم تعتمد على امرين الامر
الاول الاعداد التي ستقدم هناك 50 عربات
برادلي 40 عربه قتالدار 10 دبابات
بريطانيه اييه رقم لم يحدد بعد قد يكون
بحجم سريع اي ام اكس 10 ولكن هذه الاعداد
متواضعه نعم تحدث فارق تعطي القدره على
شان هجمات تعرضيه محدوده ولكن اذا كان ال
ال الغايه من هذا التجويد هو من اجل تاهيل
الجيش الاوكراني لهجوم الربيع القادم
علينا ان نتحدث عن مضاعفه هذه الارقام
بلا اقول بعشرات المرات على الاقل لتكون
بحجم كثير من كل نوع بدات الحديث بالقول
ان هذا سيشكل تجاوزا للخطوط الحمراء ما
نوع هذا التجاوز ولماذا تقدم عليها الدول
الغربيه باعتقادك
لماذا هناك الجمله من الاسباب هناك اسباب
سياسيه وهناك اسباب اقتصاديه واسباب
اجتماعيه الاسباب السياسيه اعتقد ان الامر
يتعلق بالجانب العملي لماذا لانه الان
اييي انقضاء عام 2023 يعني
توقيت فارق البدء بالتحذير للانتخابات
الرئيس مقبله اذا دعيني اقول يحاول الحزب
الديمقراطي ان يقدم كل ما يستطيع تقديمه
من اجل انهاء هذه الحرب سواء بالتفاوض او
همم بجبار روسيا على تقديم تنازلات بالبعد
الاقتصادي الكلي يعلم ماذا يجري الان في
الدول الاوروبيه من حيث ارتفاع اسعار
المحروقات او اسعار الطاقه بصوره عامه
والاضرابات التي بدات تحدث في بريطانيا
وفرنسا وغيرها وبالتالي لابد من تقصيره
حمد الحرب في البعد الاجتماعي عمليات
المهاجرين
الطرف الروسي يقول ان كل هذه الاسلحه لن
تغير في موازين القوى الى اي مدى هذا
الامر واقعيا باعتقادك باختصار لو سمحت
دبابات كتيبه عربات برادلي كتيبه اي ام
اكس
تغييرا جوهريا وفارقا وستبكن القوات
الاخرانيه من شن هجمات تعرضيه وقد لا
افاجا ان يهاجموا من خلال سوبر روجيا
ميلاتوبيل اذا ما توفر هذه الاعداد
الشكر اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
والعسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من عمان
[موسيقى]
لصرعتي والازمات اسماها فقد ادت قفزه في
تكلفه معظم السلع الغذائيه الاوليه العامه
الماضي نتيجه مخاوف من حدوث شح في المواد
الغذائيه اسراء حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
ادت الى ارتفاع مؤشر الاسعار الصادر عن
منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه التابعه للامم
المتحده الى اعلى مستوياتها على الاطلاق
نحو
828 مليون شخص يبيتون كل ليله وبطولهم
خاويه هذا يقولوا هكذا يقول برنامج الغذاء
العالمي اي ان اكثر من عشر البشريه يتطور
جوعا فضلا عن 50 مليون يقفون على حافه
النجاح مع ذلك يبقى الامل في ان تخص حده
الازمات الناجمه عن الصدمات المناخيه
والنزاعات والضغوط الاقتصاديه حتى يختلف
عامنا الجديد عن صديقه الذي اطلق عليه
اسمه عامل جوع غير المسبوق شكرا لكم
مشاهدينا على حسن المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]